it's time for screen junkies boobie
bytes Oh what in the world its movie
fights live everybody what's going on
has technically fights live welcome to
movie fights it is a it's the most
glamorous movie fights alcohol because
it's dedicated to this weekend's Academy
Awards and I also want to shout out
hashtag gala nation what up here's
Percival hoot-hoot
let's meet our combatants first up you
know from the real rejects channel he
has just rocketed up the movie fights
food chain and he's but always gives us
a great fight and he brought on a little
controversy around here recently because
he left here not with the movie fights
belt he left here with something almost
as precious what was it it was the
bathroom key I have never gotten more
tweets in my life about anything and I
made sure to bring it today let me let
me ask like Dan or Danielle or Billy our
producer is the bathroom key on the line
no that's going home you've you've
caused some great movie fighters and
several potty dance it's always great to
have you back brother
next up oh you can hear on the force
center podcast and I'm very excited he
and mr. lon Harris the professor himself
I have a game of Thrones centric podcast
called I love a good pun cast early talk
welcome back to the party Kenan EPSA I
am so happy to be here how clark and
cucumber this is going to be a great
match today i can't always great to have
your brother and last but not least from
the Schmo down and DC daily oh welcome
back to the party oh Clark hello thank
you for having me great to have you
Clark thanks for being here we're ready
to throw down about the most exciting
night in entertainment or one of them
anyway
Oscar's uh and deciding today's battles
will be myself and the folks on the damn
cam Dan Morelle Danielle Radford ah damn
good to see you Dan so if we both were
in shark shirts now yes I'm cheating on
our nation just a little bit but owls
will always be first on my heart but got
it when you got a good Josh shirt you
got a rep it I you don't have to tell me
how hell yeah oh you got jaws phonecase
socks everything unmentionables I'm
wearing hey I'm wearing shark socks
today oh wow Wow nicely done
yeah I like the coordination thank you
very nice and we have our social chair
the social media ambassador Daniel
Radford the great Daniel Radford
Danielle would you please tell us what
your capacity is over there and how
you're gonna be holding it down alright
so as you all probably know some of you
may not I end voice of the people know
these dudes vote in the case where it is
a tire there isn't a for sure winner we
come in and our vote actually matters
now there are lots of fun polls there's
stuff on Twitter I encourage you to join
in on the fun
but the only
all that matters in this case is the one
on YouTube if you're not sure how that
works click in the description below ask
anyone in the chat we will make sure
that you do but also I will be trolling
not rolling hash tag on Twitter
making sure checking for any kind of
there's always great photo shops you'll
always have fantastic alternative
answers so please get in there because
if I like your comment I might shut you
out of the show awesome and who indeed
Danielle but would you troll a couple of
fools today I don't wanna be on the
slide you know you're like the opposite
of the troll of a troll you bring like
sunshine good things like you say funny
stuff trolls yeah that like that's bad
juju so yeah you're the opposite so just
a reminder how our little game works the
first person to four points wins the top
two performers after the first three
rounds we'll move on to the speed round
and y'all can be down 3-0 going into the
speed round and someone can make a
furious comeback and take the whole darn
thing so what do you say without further
ado jte would you please drop that sick
ass package
[Music]
okay so you know the big prize coming
out this weekend is Best Picture our
first question is Best Picture related
but not involving the nominees what
pictures that wasn't nominated what
movie that wasn't nominated should win
Best Picture
okay so we're gonna hear about some of
the some of the snubs right now and
which one is the top of the snow heap
and we'll start with player number one
Greg yay I'm so not sick of talking
about the Oscars already funny how the
ceremony hasn't even happened yet but if
there was a picture I would have to pick
and this movie was recommended by jte
himself and I really did love this movie
it's called blind spotting and it is
without a doubt one of the best yet most
overlooked movies of last year and I've
it not all people saw so I'll give a
quick breakdown of it it tells a story
of a black man in Oakland California
named Colin played by daveed Diggs who
was on his final three days of probation
and his struggles to make sure
everything goes okay where he won't be
sent back to jail or his probation
doesn't get extended and his main
conflicts primarily deal with his white
childhood best friend played by named
Miles played by Rafael Cassell and
traumatic repercussions after witnessing
a black man gunned down by a police
officer and is without a doubt one of
the most nuanced films I solved last
year with some of the best social
commentary that deals with a variety of
things gentrification cultural
appropriation racial identities
consequences of past mistakes the
harmful lines of loyalty with your
friends and your roots PTSD and police
brutality of course yet with all this
gravitas and multiple layers and social
commentary it still manages to not be a
preachy film because of the life and
energy infused in front of n behind the
camera
it puts its characters journeys first
and foremost so the commentary naturally
unfolds through them because it's just a
truly strongly you know a character
driven piece and the two main leads and
the work behind the camera being so much
life to the performances they feel like
real people so not only is it
thought-provoking emotion
powerful educating it's also
surprisingly really funny which makes it
all around a wildly entertaining
engaging film all right a strong opening
from Greg I don't know if you'd hear jte
applauding it from the booth
disregard yes we love JT ease applause
will not sway us Ken knapsack vote
online JT great description I I have not
seen it I know Janina gavankar is in it
the voice of ID and versio and Star Wars
battlefronts on big fan of hard work so
it you've given a great pitch it's gonna
be tough to tear down any one of these
choices every year there's a lot of
great snubs you could make a case for a
lot of these I am making the case today
or trying to make the case for both
Barnum's eighth grade now this is a
movie that is a quiet tone poem about
real-life grown up across many
generations I think this is of its time
but it's also something I resonated with
me taking taking me back to eighth grade
and it's about I think personal identity
and and and finding yourself in any kind
of world but particularly world now I
like what Gregg saying about blind
spotting and the fact that it's dealing
with heavy things but it doesn't become
preachy well that's I think what eighth
grade does to it's so quiet in the way
it delivers things at times I thought I
was watching a documentary or at least
felt like it it hearkened back to
something like the wrestler with me
having worked in pro wrestling's like I
thought oh this is Jeff they've just put
up a camera in real life I thought
that's what it did and I believe a lot
of the big issues of these big Oscar
movies deal with this one goes down to
the core about personal identity
confidence and trying to navigate tough
waters that start very early which can
either lead or correct problems later on
in life so I'm going bow Burnham's it's
great all right Ken here talking about
bow Burnham's eighth grade Clark okay so
I picked it I did a different approach I
I really kind of thought a lot about the
Oscars and the Oscar problem that you
know something that we we talk about as
fans a lot the Oscars don't necessarily
they feel they're trying to become more
inclusive and representative all the
time but the big blockbuster fill
that actually have something to say
often still get overlooked now this year
of course Black Panther was able to
break through which was fantastic but so
I I decided to give a little love to a
quiet place so I think that a quiet
place was the best movie that wasn't
nominated for Best Picture of the year I
think that this movie in addition to
address it so so what I like about it is
that it is a mainstream film absolutely
but it's a well-done heart-felt
well-crafted
mainstream film when we're talking about
Oscar snubs a lot of people also are
talking about Emily Blunt the fact that
she sort of was overlooked not only for
her performance and Mary Poppins returns
but for this movie as well and I think
that for me
you know her performance in this film
mostly silent by the way if anybody has
forgotten because it has been about a
year since this came out was was
absolutely remarkable and um you know I
the last thing I would say is when I
come on in this show I'm often
advocating for genre film I think that
John were film doesn't necessarily get
the love that it deserves I don't Greg
you're a big genre fan as well and I
think that a quiet place is a wonderful
example of of you know genre done well
and when and when Jean redun well it can
be heartfelt it can be scary it can be
moving it can be well-crafted
and it can be well acted and all of
those things are what a quiet place ed
and it resonated with audiences Wow
three pretty different films all strong
choices fight it out please this is
gonna be this is gonna be very tough to
fight it's just gonna be a nice polite
debate because I love what I love quiet
place and I love what you're presenting
again I admit I haven't seen what you're
saying but that might be the problem the
Oscars is at the end of days still a
popularity contest still a who can get
the money behind the campaign and this
one sadly overlooked
dude I agree this is
you did a great job as your laughs I was
like the dice I didn't say anything
funny yeah go for it no well I I think
the things that make a quiet place
strong and eighth grade I think eighth
grade is known for two main things Elsi
Fisher's performance and Bo Burnham
scripting and and I think for a quiet
place a lot of the technical parameters
are what it's really known for its sound
design its editing and well the lack of
sound design basically the technical
structure side I think what blind
spotting does so remarkably well is it
does both of those elements in this
movie just as good in blind spot it like
if you look at eighth grade you're
looking into a slice-of-life of
someone's lifestyle of what the horrors
and anxieties of that person's life must
be like and blind spotting does that
with our two main leads and with a quiet
place they know when you think about the
technical parameters this film not on
beyond its character stuff the directing
of it it sound transitions it's its use
of color palette and the way that the
director uses everything about that
movie is so composed so yes while I love
to lean in on character work with this
movie I also think behind the camera
it's just as powerful where's a quiet
place I don't really I feel like with a
quiet place if that had won best picture
or even got nominated I feel like it
would have been a lot of backlash for
that because that's the kind of movie
where I feel like and I'll give you a
chance to rebuttal it is I I feel like
with a quiet place that's the kind of
movie that when you re watch it or when
you look back on it or watch it at home
I think when you watch it in the
theaters you let a lot of the logic go
but you have to really suspend your
disbelief in order for that movie to
work I don't necessarily agree with that
assessment because I saw in the theater
with a packed house and I also watched
it at home with only one other person
and for me all of the things that a
quiet place was trying to hit home the
family struggle you know and and what
parents will do and what one will do for
the loved ones that they care about in
dire situations I think all of that
works whether you're at home or you're
in the theater I also think like to echo
what Ken said I don't really want to
like take down either of these
Bisby or any of these three movies
because I feel like they're all very
valid but what I feel like is important
to argue is that a quiet place offers
the entire package that once again
resonated with audiences I feel like
when we are talking about bringing the
Oscars forward and making them become
something that you know people at large
enjoy we want to see the movies that we
just love represented what a quiet place
has in addition to being a movie that we
just love it is technically proficient
and as far as performances go um you
know I I apologize I don't have her name
in front of me but the young lady who
plays the daughter you know that is a
deaf at an example of a deaf actress
playing a deaf character that that
performance that she gives is absolutely
beautiful and a heartfelt not to mention
the performance once again the Emily
Blunt gifts so I don't necessarily agree
that a quiet place is only should only
be loud it for its technical
achievements because also those scares
those technical achievements they don't
work unless you're invested in the story
and this is at its core and emotional
family drama about the choir plays which
I really loved is is when you look at
Best Picture winners and we're saying
these were nominated but we think they
could have won or should have won right
so you're gonna look down on a list
you're gonna scan on Wikipedia and the
movies gonna be of its time but not of
its time quiet place I don't know if it
will stand the test of time it's beyond
just what we experienced this this year
with it and any less the lessons are
great they're universal as well the
parental but I don't know if there any
new lessons that are revelant relevant
to to this time and then go and beyond
sorry I don't know looking back if quiet
place will have as as the impact as it
did right now as a pop culture piece
which he was it was one of the things
you have to see it I get scared real
easily in movies I think you know this
about me Clark I can't even listen to
any podcast you know I'm talking about
horror I was forced to watch that movie
and I came out the other side I learned
a lot but I felt III got more from what
I ate grade that Here I am an old guys
grandma beard
almost reliving the trauma of being in
that year but also finding you know just
the way that casually but in a Buick
sadly beautiful casual way of going
through active shooter training like
it's just part of their lives and they
and just seeing how
how you have to establish yourself now
and I think that stands the test time
you look back for the time in the era I
think your movie probably has that too
Greg Greg from what you're describing
you're gonna look back and say all right
that has some relevance now and forever
we're quite placenta hopeful stand up to
that test of time yeah I feel like with
a quiet place I think the performance is
elevated I think the writing of the
characters is rather bland in that movie
I don't really I don't even know those
characters names I don't I don't think
you're supposed to I think the idea is
that they could literally be anything
there like avatars in a way for you to
live through that they're not really I
don't really feel through that nuance of
characters okay I don't agree with
already explained why I feel that's like
your opinion then let's shift gears
everybody and some great arguments all
around let's move to our final thoughts
and we'll start with player number one
greg alba i think that a film that
should win best picture should be a film
that nails at all if not most of it here
you have an amazing truly lived in
performance from its lead and its
supporting cast which brings a lot of
weight and humor acquitting to
performances of just life the writing
and direction of this film is
unbelievably sharp clever energetic
realistic and uniquely told to where you
don't know how the film will ultimately
unfold but by the time it ends it takes
your breath away the use of colors
symmetry editing all clearly perfectly
composed and thought-out from beginning
to end
the sound design with its transitions
and it manages to be a phone with a lot
of humor and a lot of weight even it's
more surreal elements its nightmarish
sequences and its use of rap used in the
movie for its main character to be able
to express what he normally can't in
regular conversation and like i said in
my opening the commentary on
gentrification racial identity is all
different multiple themes of PTSD in
police brutality and it's not preachy
because the film puts its characters
first and there are scenes in this movie
of confrontation that are more powerful
and more intense and I saw all year that
I find more scary I think there are
scenes in eighth grade and this movie
that are more intense and scarier than
anything in a quiet place the
confrontation at the very end of this
movie with a police officer the scene
where a baby is holding a child holding
a gun and the subplots with the
girlfriends are also very resonant for
the characters I think
to wrap it up I'd say the main strengths
of eighth grade in a quiet place I
believe are demonstrated so much in
blind spotting as well with a quiet
place things that it's primarily
credited for its like yes some people
really love emily Blunt's acting and
such but i think the things that's
mainly acknowledged for the shark
direction horror use of sound design and
editing blind spotting expertly nails
that hates grades credit for stepping
into the life of a character and
exploring the horrors and anxieties of
what it must be like to be that person
this movie also nails that so while I
think your guys's movies have strong
elements I don't think it's the whole
package the strengths of what their
films are recognized for this film also
does exceedingly well and does more up
every single element in front of them
behind the camera of blind spotting
shines it's a more important film it's a
more relevant film has a lot more nuance
every single scene is multi-layered and
the entertainment value is also there
thanks Greg and impassioned speech and I
and I believe in respect every word
you've said it's might be on my list to
see but I'm putting a Best Picture
winner in a time capsule that's what's
going on in eighth grade we got time
capsules kids and when you pull this
movie out you're gonna go to that pool
party scene watching the the gift be
unwrapped and you're gonna have every
bit of horror you spent growing up of
trying to find your place trying to find
your place in the world which spills out
into all these other areas covered in
this movie in that movie you're gonna
see this one and it's going to
absolutely resonate no matter who you
are where you are and when you are
watching it it is a Best Picture winner
in my mind
thank you Ken Clark alright so I just I
want to start by saying you know at the
end of the day it we we all I feel like
Jean our films are very hard to do well
if they were easy to do well a lot more
of them would be better but they're not
and so I think the fact that a quiet
place resonated with audiences really
says something now I bring that up
because when we're thinking about the
best picture of the year you know the
Academy has long had a problem with
recognizing films that regular audiences
enjoy and what a quiet place I think
represents for 2018 is the fact that you
are you can recognize a technically a
well done film that has heart that has a
motion that it that succeeds in what it
sets out to do which is scare you and
make you cry it has it has beautiful
performances it and it from especially
led by Emily Blunt and and you know what
you were talking earlier Greg about the
entire package I feel like that is the
entire package we have 10 Best Picture
nominees for a reason the idea behind
that was to include more movies that
resonate with a wider group and I think
a quiet place should not only have been
nominated as one of those ten but it
should be recognized as the best picture
for the of the year Thank You Clark wolf
ding ding there we have it yeah
thoughtful good round
it makes me consider all those films Dan
Merle what's going on in the fact zone
not much to check factually factually
Wilson Simmons is the actor who slayed
the daughter in a quiet place she is
hearing-impaired in real life but I
played that role in the film of the
three films mentioned here today only
one of them received any Oscar attention
whatsoever a quiet place received one
Oscar nomination for some editing but
neither eighth grade nor blind spotting
received any Oscar attention however
eighth grade did win just recently it
was a surprise winner of the write the
Writers Guild or at screenplay
among some other awards and that's it
actually that's all I got excellent
thank you Dan so yeah going into this I
definitely had my opinions on these
films and I threw them out the window
and listened to these arguments and so
I'm I'm going against some of my
personal opinions because you guys
because of what you have waged here
Clark you laid out just a great argument
as to why some more popular genre films
should be included and a quiet place it
would be at the top of the list for me
and I think you hit some of the
important reasons why this film was kind
of overlooked and it deserves a lot of
love for standing out last year can a
Thwaite is a film that I love so you're
really speaking to me but I'm at the end
of the day I
Gregg just laid out the most
comprehensive argument as to why blondes
blind spotting resumes okay he laid out
the most interesting argument to me as
to why blind spotting resonated in
technical performance creative and
behind-the-scenes and the whole package
there that's what I heard from Gregg's
so that's where my vote goes dan Merle
I'm having a tough time with this I feel
like Ken got kind of caught in the
crossfire between Clark and Gregg and so
yeah I have to I have to discount ken
just for that reason and it came down to
those two and it's very close and it
comes down to they both made great cases
for why their movies were good movies
yeah I think that a lot of the things
that were thrown to both of them but
particularly at a quiet place were a bit
subjective it was it was hard because
the two good fighters both making a
passionate case what was the difference
maker for me was Greg he painted a great
picture about why blind spotting is a
great movie but I feel like Clark
addressed more why it should be at the
Oscars why it should be nominated for
Best Picture and when at the Oscars and
it wasn't what's the best movie it's
what's the movie that should be
nominated and when Best Picture at the
Oscars and I felt like you know Greg
really sold blind spotting the movie but
I think Clark sold me on the question
more as like this is why it's important
that it be included for Best Picture
specifically and is it just a great
movie it's it may seem the ticky-tack
but when you have a lot of good
arguments that's how you have to do it
yeah my vote would be for Clark based on
playing the oscar angle and playing to
the question a little more III hear
where you're coming from so it's one for
Clark and it's one for Greg Clark Craig
again this is
we are not Greg a fabulous actor but
that's why I state so we're going to
Danielle to let us to help us out here
alright so this is a just refreshed and
at 36 percent this is close a quiet
place at 35 percent blinds at 28 percent
eighth-grade in a real barnburner car
takes those points there are some other
great things people were saying into the
spider-verse can you ever forgive me
sorry to bother you it feels streak to
talk bad times which I've loved all of
these movies yes Joseph yeah so close
and then what I really enjoyed this
comment from Road Raider 3 I'm gonna hop
back up on my soapbox for annihilation
it's a truly beautiful thought-provoking
complex sci-fi movie with interesting
themes great performances and I wish
more people saw it or had the chance in
theaters I agree I thought annihilation
was great go see to begin that was my
beat choice yeah yeah girl I went to the
I should not have looked at the check
I'm sorry I'm the villain of this show
so hard
sorry guys like I see him I don't know
you voted for it too
jeez you know what comment sections
chats they can be dangerous places to
wait into and so can the movie fight
stable Clark emerges victorious on that
movie and we move to question number two
again we're talking about the most
glamorous night in Hollywood question
number two
of all the Best Picture winners we're
talking of all time since like man we're
going back to like what like 1980s
no I'm kidding like the 1920s what's the
best movie to ever win Best Picture
Wow best movie to ever win Best Picture
dan what year was the first Academy
Awards night like 29 30 and I believe
1920 oh it's so like 1929 221 something
like that every said 29 mm that's just
trivia many words were in 1920 Oh held
in 1929 yeah um so yeah just to give you
guys a little bit of context we're going
all the way back to in the way wayback
machine to 1929 they could choose any
picture between last year and 1929 and
we're gonna start with player number two
our good friend Ken knapsack Hey my
answer is sponsored by the book the
female gay Malone a guide to a central
movies made by women oh hey Alicia
Malone led me to this answer she
introduced me to this movie that I had
not washed in quite frankly there's a
lot of movies have a watch but she made
sure I watched this one and it is my
choice it happened one night the 1934
winner for Best Picture
Claudia Claudette Colbert as Ellie Clark
Gable as Peter directed by Frank Capra
being first it's not always best I don't
think that's always the answer but this
is a case where I think this movie
really really created a template for
romantic comedies screwball comedies and
movies that quote stand the test of time
there's a lot of bigger more epic
choices out there I get that but it's
kind of maybe my style to go small to go
characters to go relationships and a
movie that you can watch now or as I
didn't 2015 and feel like it was as
modern ed of as a movie in 1934 can be
happened one night by Frank Capra
all right the great Frank Capra it
happened one night Clark yes all right I
have chosen Billy Wilder's the apartment
so this is I really like this is
interesting because this fight is is
something that I care very passionately
about but I also know that I am right
just like if you guys don't agree that's
your problem the apartment is I love
this film I love it for many many
reasons
one of the things that I think makes it
the best picture to ever win best
picture or best film to ever win best
picture is that it still is contemporary
to day this is a movie that is decades
and decades old and yes it is black and
white and yes it has Jack Lemmon and
Shirley MacLaine in it but it is it is a
story about human beings it is a story
about people it is still funny to this
day when you're doing a comedy
especially a comedy that is decades old
if those jokes still land you have done
something right not only do the jokes in
the apartment still land the heartbreak
in or the apartment still lands the
performances from Jack Lemmon and
Shirley MacLaine art are absolutely
outstanding Shirley MacLaine
specifically as brand cubic and and
Billy Wilder you know he comes with this
package meaning Billy Wilder I think is
one of the greatest film directors to
ever live I think he can make you laugh
while making you cry and breaking your
heart but making you feel hopeful that's
everything wrapped up in the apartment
it's a truly beautiful film but it's
also not one of those like film school
films or it's like you have to watch
this because it's like though this is
actually a great movie I highly
recommend to anyone watching it to this
day so that's why the apartment I think
is the best movie to ever win Best
Picture
Wow such heavy hitters coming to like
the apartment with Jack Lemmon directed
by Billy Wilder Shirley MacLaine
happened one night Capra Clark Gable
Claudette Colbert alright let's add to
the party Greg what do you got mine's a
romantic comedy too called The Godfather
Oh
the 2015 hit rate if you haven't
happened to have seen the Godfather I'm
just gonna read you the IMDB description
if you just happen having to see in this
movie the ancient patriarch of organized
crime yes it's about the aging patriarch
of an organized-crime dynasty who
transfers control his clandestine Empire
to his reluctant son when I was thinking
about this question I was trying to
think of the movie that's had the most
cultural impact and the biggest impact
and influence on film makers and the
film medium as a whole and without a
doubt The Godfather is the one that has
just transcended movies over the decades
as I think out of all these pics
especially it is not just the most
iconic but easily the most influential
film of them all and and it's also very
very timeless and explores a wide
variety of themes of family loyalty
ethnic identity culture legacy good
versus eagle the eagle good versus evil
struggles with what it means to be a man
loneliness greed all told through what
it's probably the best ensemble ever put
together on the big screen and I feel
like I know a movie feisty argue a lot
of subjective point of views but the
Godfather is one of the movies that is
objectively regarded as one of the
absolute greatest most influential
movies ever made which I like just some
quick credits and I'll wrap it up
it was selected for preservation in the
u.s. National Film registry the Library
of Congress being deep culturally at the
cultural historically and aesthetically
significant second greatest film ranked
by AFI in American cinema only behind
Citizen Kane what number one at
Metacritic top 100 list ranked seventh
are on tomatoes all-time best list
number two and IMDB Stanley Kubrick
himself thought it was the best one many
made ever made so for many of its iconic
scenes ridiculous amount of quotable
lines powerhouse performances
beautifully shot scenes from beginning
to end its iconic score epics sprawling
violent tale that manages to remain
engage Lea intimate emotional and a wide
variety of ways throughout for me it was
just a no brainer as The Godfather
all right fight it out so we can solve
this easy question yeah this is no
problem this is this
very tell you why in the apartment and
then hold on are bad news okay so so
I'll I'll start it off okay uh with the
Godfather yes um I think that it's easy
for us to wrap the entire Godfather saga
up into the Godfather I think a lot of
people when they talk about the impact
and standing the test of time yes of
course the first film is is mention all
those accolades are true but I think the
true cultural impact really wraps up the
Godfather and the Godfather Part two and
I think that's where it gets a little
sticky with saying with with Loudon the
Godfather as the best because I think
you a lot of people think of the
combination when they think of the
Godfather and and so I don't know if the
Godfather on its own would be able to
stand as the best the best movie to win
best that's more of a theory that sounds
very subjective because I mean I'm just
going off the facts here with what all
the accolades it's received over time
and I for me personally I don't I don't
I don't because I know you're saying
that you do but for me I don't lump both
Godfather one and two together well I
think Godfather T was an amazing film it
was actually my option B for this one I
don't I don't really associate them I
can really look at them as individual
pieces together and it seems like well
the thing about it happened when I which
actually saw just last year and it was a
really fun movie and the apartment as
well I feel like when this comes to this
question I'm thinking of every single
element that involves making a film
beyond its impact and its iconic nasai
all the design aesthetic to it as well
and for me when I look back at it
happened one night or the apartment
which are both really great films the
main thing I think of when you show a
person that today if it's the first time
they're watching it they're primarily
gonna take away two things the
performances and the writing where I
think with The Godfather you take away
everything directing the epic storyline
performances writing the production
design the music every single thing
about that picture and why how its
implemented Scorsese's Goodfellas or The
Sopranos
if it
wasn't for the Godfather I think okay
I'm also there argue meet kindly
crossfire no don't be nice clerk but
here I'll tell you what I think a lot of
my fans know I have like four of them
I'm one of those people I was in film
school sat down to watch Godfather wait
like this four minutes I'm out
I could go watch Goodfellas I can go
watch casino never seen it to this day
it's like the wall by Pink Floyd yep
it's part of history but it's wallpaper
I pass by going to find something that
connects more with me on a personal
level and that has great influences you
if you watch it happened one night
you're gonna go through go that's I
think I love what Harry Met Sally that's
from this this that's from that in fact
you're gonna watch even the apartment
and go oh really well there must have
watched it happened one night you can
find the same kind of vibe now I again
how am I gonna tear down that movie cuz
the end gets me emotionally good but I'm
talking about putting it down on paper
as the best trying to take my personal
stuff out there I remember watching it
happen one night just go I get it this
is the template for so many things that
came before it and I'm still gonna watch
something now and tie it back to that
where I think you could say Godfather to
did surpass Godfather sums that's
obviously not my opinion own to have
that opinion or or Goodfellas or jte he
likes bringing out the dead it's a weird
Scorsese choice but yeah I think yours
is absolutely great like you know what
happen One Nights got Awards twelve
BAFTAs seven Nick jr. Teen Choice Awards
it was in the 1934 Baseball Hall of Fame
with Ty Cobb and Babe Ruth I don't know
the ward it doesn't matter to me because
it's just it's just noise we're getting
into a conversation too and it's so hard
to do in this in this environment but I
love this debate because what we're
talking about is what we value in film
and I think Greg the thing with the
Godfather is that that's a taste issue
you even said it in your argument what
it means to be a man and for me as a
cinephile as somebody who went to film
school it was one of many things I
because I think it kind of effects and
informs the rest of your argument you're
talking about taste for you does that go
like right for both of you though - no
like likewise no it doesn't because I
would argue that what your movie does is
it represents a certain type of man a
certain type of figure a certain type of
story something like the apartment I
would argue is universal it's a man it's
a woman it's a love story it's trying to
get ahead in in your career it's B it's
deception it's learning that it's
dealing with heartache it's dealing with
suicide it's dealing with so many life
things that I feel like all people in
general could relate to when I watch The
Godfather
I don't relate to it and I'm gonna be
completely honest because you know this
is a debate show um I think the
Godfather is one of the greatest movies
of all time and I do think it is
influential but I don't think it is I
don't think it is the gold standard that
everybody that done a lot of people in
our community hold it up to me I feel
like there's so many themes and so many
different it's like an emotional
rollercoaster The Godfather there yeah
for some there's so many elements in
that movie though I mean there is that
romantic element of the romance he forms
in Italy and the loss that he has and
the strain relationship he has with
Diane Keaton in that movie uh Al
Pacino's and then there is the father
and son dynamic and there's also the
brother and sister relationship with
Talia Shire the whole movie it's an
interesting movie because it's a it's a
criminal organization movie but it's
also a lot about family it was the first
movie there was like a whole censorship
board thing that was an issue where if
he had villains as the main characters
they had to be portrayed as bad and it
was the first movie to take villain
characters and portray them with a lot
of heart and humanity in a relatable way
and that's why I don't think if it was
not relatable if there was nothing
that's what made it so compelling was
that even though their villainous
characters we latch on to them not just
because they're interesting but because
it's about family at the end of it it
quote bindis on that whole franchise
it's about family
while comparing it to Greg Lex Dean and
Olive Garden barely where it's all about
family can the floor is yours
Martha look I look we keep saying this
but this is a tough one because I get
your influences are absolutely 100%
right I also think though another person
in the seat or another person your seat
could have selected Lawrence of Arabia
could have selected Ben Hur could have
selected Shakespeare in Love kitty about
some big giant epic movie that everyone
studies and brings out books and says
this is what you need to to like I I'm
looking at if I'm being honest the
apartment is actually my favorite of
these movies but I think it happened one
night is a better movie than that when
you're talking about the best of all
time and and it's hard to compare eras
that's that's true in a lot of things
but I I do think going back to my
original argument a lot of things tie
back to this one which is I I think it
is the best and Stan's intestine
thank you kidnap Zach Clark wolf so I
think that you know when it comes to
when it comes to movies like The
Godfather what we're talking about is
impact and influence and that's very
important but I don't necessarily think
that equals best to me the thing the
question the question is what's the best
movie to ever win Best Picture
so to me what the apartment has that
these other two don't is it has
relatability for anyone in the audience
because I watch The Godfather and I do
not relate to Kate and oh do I not
relate to Talia Shire so that's a whole
other debate but I think you can watch
Frank Oobleck I think you can watch the
watch Baxter and you can say yep I have
been in one of those positions in
addition to that we're talking about
quality the writing the direction the
performances the atmosphere that is
created in Billy Wilder's the apartment
is is undeniable and finally I think the
question is does it stand the test of
time and when you are doing romance and
when you are doing comedy it is so hard
to have a movie
stands the test of time that is still
funny that still resonates and I would
argue that with the apartment the only
thing that doesn't stand the test of
time is his New York City apartment
going for like three hundred dollars a
month
everything else is something that you
can look at and you go yeah that's me
and you can laugh out loud so for me I
absolutely believe that the apartment is
the best movie to ever win Best Picture
Thank You Clark Gregg I I feel like okay
we're in a very subjective round here
and when it comes to relatability I when
I watched it happen one night and the
apartment I didn't go there and go I
relate I don't relate with these
characters I don't I don't identify with
these guys and the relatability is just
as subjective as a lot of things that
we're talking about today so I'm
thinking about what has real you've got
to think about the best picture ever and
its influence and impact it has made
over the Kliq forty five years later and
it's still influencing films today and
these if you haven't seen the guy and
it's like if you haven't seen the
Godfather you will have seen a reference
in so many movies whether it's a comedy
movie or even a drama or a show even and
the amount of like iconic quotes in that
film there's more quotes and scenes in
those movies that are way more memorable
and way more famous in the mainstream
than any of your movies I can't recall
as a specific scene from your guys's
stuff maybe it happened one night with
the lifting up the dress part but that's
about it but with like the iconic quotes
I'm gonna make him an offer he can't
refuse
leave the gun leave the gun take the
cannoli sleep with the fishes now and
then all the scenes in there that are so
memorable listening to the opening scene
of marlon brando listening to a man's
plea for help the entire wedding the
horse's head in the bed the restaurant
scene with Pacino Sonny at the toll
booth that the orange slices in Brando's
mouth the iconic image of Diane Keaton
watching the door closed on Pacino and
this film hafstrom of criminal
characters yet it feel it's weirdly
feels a lot about family it has a
surprising amount of heart and wide
variety of motions you feel throughout
the journey their suspense intensity
costs an intrigue romance heartbreak
loss shock fear you watch characters
true emotions become unraveled over the
course of this film from guilt and
remorse these are all emotions we can
relate to and you're also watching a man
try to separate himself
his family but they get sucked back in
too and this is in the first movie gets
sucked back into the lifestyle of his
family that is toxic for him a lot of us
can relate to that and I think it
happened one night in the apartment are
great films that are not as timeless
you're not as nowhere near as
influential or as iconic and they feel
like a strong product of its time you've
had works that I've come out that are
similar but I think there are some works
later or even better or improved upon
when you watch those movies today you
probably only take away the acting and
the script they're fine movies but only
a couple elements of this day of really
shine with the Godfather the last thing
I'll say direction scope music
cinematography production design writing
performances the amount of emotions you
experience along the way it's the entire
package and that's why it's this iconic
as it is it still holds up to this day
45 years later it has a continuing long
lasting effect on culture and cinema
it's practically perfect
ring-a-ding-ding that is the end of
round two Dan Merle please take us to
the fact zone and then give us your
thoughts on this battle I get to go
first great actually I'm glad someone
else can break the tight okay all of
these films nominated by the Academy
Awards obviously they all won Best
Picture they were else they wouldn't
have been eligible for this round it
happened one night won five Oscars and
one what's referred to as the big five
which only a few movies have done
picture director actor actress and
screenplay the apartment also on five
Oscars picture director screenplay
art direction and editing no acting an
Oscars for that film which I am a big
fan of and I think that's a that's a
travesty the apart yeah yeah it didn't
which a crown or certainly whoa that's
crazy McMurray
yeah wow that's a Godfather did not what
is what the Oscars is I think a lot of
people might have yeah because it was a
kind of a stacked year that year it want
it did not win Best Director like people
think Copeland won Best Director for The
Godfather he did not it won three Oscars
including the Best Picture Best Actor
and Best Adapted Screenplay
I don't know if you still have at your
fingertips did you who I'm just curious
who won Best Director wasn't an Aussie I
believe it was Bob Fosse at war that was
cabaret that year so basically it was
like The Godfather and cabaret yeah
split all of the big one phrases Joel
Grey beat Pacino
for Best Supporting whereas cuz it was
Brando that won best actor contest of
the awards though because he thought I
should have been lead oh yeah Bob Fosse
won yeah very good
yeah damn what you think oh boy the
subjective ones are tough um again Ken
I'm sorry you got caught in the middle
okay I'd love to see it's the right to
have around but this one it'll just be
Kendall you guys have great candy in the
room but really it it actually felt sort
of like everyone against Greg in a large
part because the Godfather and what it
means which I think it could be a
positive or could be a negative
ultimately I think that Greg was able to
fight himself out of being boxed in on
several things I thought that Clark's
relatability argument was a very strong
argument I mean that was really swaying
me but I thought that Greg had it had a
great counter to that and he got more
thrown at him against his choice than
any other competitor but at the same
time I thought that he was able to fight
back and then go further than anyone
else in this round so my vote would go
great you know what Dan I gotta say I'm
just about in lockstep with you here
because I thought Clark made a brilliant
argument trying to take down the
behemoth that is the Godfather because
there's so much baggage and stuff that
goes with the Godfather um Ken and Clark
dinging you on Oh does it get lumped in
with Godfather two and then I thought
your relatability argument was brilliant
and it is such a like a masculinity
centric thing to see to like see
yourself navigating that Godfather world
and watching that film and relating to
those characters so that was that was a
wonderful argument Clark but at the end
of the day I thought Greg addressed it
oh there's more than that like I had to
be reminded that there's more than just
that relatability that's how good your
your fight was Clark and yeah I think
reminded us why this film is just on the
Mount Rushmore movies so I'm going Greg
as well Godfather and Greg take a point
Danielle where we at as part of the
polls oh gee I can't wait to hear it
six three four we have the Godfather the
apartment at 20% and it happened one
night at 15% I'll take it
ken made it III don't think you should
overlook just how important the point
that Ken made though as far as it giving
birth to so many of the jobs my health
and introduced me to them yes because of
that fact and so um some other things
that were said a lot of return of the
Kings One Flew Over the Cuckoo's Nest
Godfather - got a lot of love forego
rocky and good are Goodwin I know but
that's what they keep saying is messing
with me today and they just really need
me to say crash and they're pretending
like they crash into every single crash
if you're not in the Chad get in the
chat they're having a great time
trolling me a lot of fun crash talk
crashed in the chat and was it jte who
who wrote we did rocky yes thank you
probably all right so we are locked up
at 1 1 1 for Clarke one for Greg and we
are going into question number three
which is a surprise I've never done -
I've never done more oh yeah guess what
it's a blind fight look out whoa what
omg omg there are multiple half
okay all right all right
this question was inspired by the
casting of Chris Hemsworth as Paul Cogan
guys so I'm going to ask each of you to
pick one piece of paper out of each hat
okay one night be 100 each one one
reach-in why okay
reach and reach in stand you down how
staring you down all right there you
have it so you have you know I haven't
I'm gonna need Billy to come over and
help me out with this iPad in a second
but I remember this question you each
chose an actor or actress and a and a
biography a biographical subject so you
are going to pitch us the biopic
starring this actor or actress etc and
it's question number three I think I got
two actors two performers right yes it's
right it's right whatever it is it's
right all right let's go around the
table and hear who you have and you can
give us as much or as little info about
your particular movie as you care to so
would you like to hear the picture now
or would you like to either your player
is you're ready let her rip Clark of
course I'm ready are you kidding
hell yeah okay ladies and gentlemen Adam
driver is the voice of his generation he
is considered by many to be one of the
best young
actors working today I think he has a
long road ahead of him he was great and
girls and he's great in black Klansmen
and of course he's got the high profile
Star Wars movies who doesn't love an
atom driver so who better to play the
iconic restaurateur chef Disher
the man who represents most of America
when it comes to our eating habits guy
feeding I mean just think Adam driver is
a community he and he's one of the most
intense actors III he shaped shifts he
disappears into his roles and I think
that there is nobody better to portray
the man the myth and the Time Square
legend
Guy Fieri great opening salvo and I will
say to everyone also please think about
who you'd want to direct your film and
who might take some plums supporting
roles Greg what do you got we lost a man
recently who has played such an
influence in our culture an iconic man
who found in Marvel Comics named Stan
Lee and we all want a biopic of him so
who better to portray him than Michael B
Jordan yes Thank You Clark you're
welcome
helping you that well I appreciate that
Michael B Jordan is always being told
that he should play all kinds of roles
even asked to play Superman lately and
you know we're always saying how we need
more diversity in the comic book
character roles what better way to
really implement the diversity than to
go to the actual origin the source of it
all that having Michael B Jordan span
the entire lifespan of Stan Lee in the
course of this this biopic all right
thank you Greg look for X by Ryan
Coogler okay
you know it's Michael B Jordan and she
won't work with anyone else yep that's a
great combo thank you Greg
Ken nap sock what are you working with
you know they say the world is sick of
said of little love songs but I think if
you look around you you'll see it isn't
so in the late 1960s Paul McCartney then
of the Beatles met a young Linda Eastman
at a event promoting sergeant pepper's
Lonely Hearts Club Band and thus began a
love affair that lasted for ages until
her tragic passing of cancer so that is
why Duncan Jones will be directing
Michelle Williams in the Paul McCartney
related biopic Matilda sweet as Paul
McCartney called the wind beneath his
wings come on wait Michelle Williams is
directing this she started as as as Paul
McCartney biopic is The Wiz beneath his
wind till the sweatin will be Paul
McCartney directed by Duncan Jones son
of David Bowie
alright fight it out please look I would
love to go to flavortown I think guy
Ferrari is a underrated a big-hearted
person who goes around helping the world
but I love Adam driver he's my favorite
actor in the new Star Wars sequel era I
think he brings so much but I think he's
gonna bring too much I think we need
someone who's gonna just explode on the
screen with fun and joy I think a
Channing Tatum would have been a great
choice but you were stuck with Adam
driver and I think we're good outgoing
to flavortown I think we're going to
mood town with your film little did you
know that Michael Bay is going to be
directing flavortown
do you see pain and gain this is his new
pain and Kate about it the sex the drugs
the fried foods all on display Adam
driver is the only person to do this and
it's going to co-star Kristen Wiig as a
cheeseburger
it's going to co-star Paul Giamatti as
he is beard it's going to be epic
and nobody can make this work it's
Michael Bay make that just god-awful
here maybe painting gayness is like it's
the good version compared to all the bad
movies he's done yeah but when he shows
up for a thoughtful character piece
which how could that's not blue guys
Ryan Coogler Michael B Jordan and I have
made they haven't made one bad movie two
beautiful film teams you put them
together you're guaranteed a moving
picture that is also wildly picture
that's wildly engaging and I think you
know with the Stan Lee life that we've
all known of how he struggled to I need
to not look at Daniel Radford as a Stan
Lee life of we know that he liked it was
that the 60s or 70s when he was trying
to do Marvel Comics and everyone was
looking down upon him and those times
imagine if you infuse those kind of
struggles of race relations through it
all so Michael B Jordan as Stanley in
here I think Stanley would want a more
fictionalized version of his roots a
more fictionalized version of someone
having really had to overcome some
that's how x-men came to be for its
metaphors for racism and I think you can
do that with this movie too it doesn't
stand we already kind of have a
fictionalized biographer and all the
comics that he kind of created on other
people's shoulders like it's your movie
movie gonna deal what that doesn't sound
like it just sounds like it's gonna make
an idol out of someone who was great and
definitely brought a lot once you peel
back the layers you're gonna find some
darkness and you don't want to face
where me you've got a love story that
everyone just can get behind you can go
to the early 70s when he McCartney left
the Beatles and
citing you know who I'm gonna work with
the woman I love and everyone in the
world said what are you crazy and he
said absolutely in love with Linda
now McCartney in this picture how she
turned him into a vegetarian how on
their farm the MU love kins here they
were watched she stared out at the at
the sheep and was like honey I can't do
the della Estella Estella McCartney son
James McCartney good musician plays with
Danny Harrison to mail a lot about each
of you Clark I want to know from you
who's going to play Emeril Lagasse and
Greg I want to know from you who's gonna
play Steve Ditko and Ken I want to know
from you who's gonna play John Lennon
let's start with Clark
well Emeril is going to be played also
by Paul Giamatti because he's amazing
and also if we're looking at
oscar-worthy biopics
I mean I feel like you can't have one
without Paul Giamatti and the problem
with casting Michelle Williams my dear
friend is that the Oscars hate her so
you're not gonna win any Oscars if
Michelle Williams is in your movie
Oscars love and this is the greatest
love story of all time can love win an
Oscar Gregg who's gonna play Steve Ditko
uh did Daniel Cole ooh yeah yeah you
just really commit to what we're doing
here with this movie you get I mean with
the Black Panther being the first MCU
movie to be nominated why not pull the
director and the cast from that
powerhouse sensation that Black Panther
is and then you tell this Stan Lee I
mean your vision is coming in there were
so many struggles that Stanley had to go
through in order to make Marvel Comics
what it is today that lasted just
decades and out of all of our actors
Michael B Jordan is the one who has
demonstrated the most range and the most
engaging energy out of everyone here on
this panel thank you that Stanley what
about John Lennon John Lennon
will be played by Christian Bale you're
gonna find that wow I cannot believe you
transition right now you're thinking
right now John Lennon
Christian Bale at the glasses Oh give
good for you give peace a chance all
right good work everybody
wow you guys got real things I got guy
fatty like come on guys Oh Guy Fieri's a
fun ride to flavortown Dan what happened
with the blacks in that round oh so many
things
ya know anything's happen with the facts
a couple Guy Fieri is it's a Time Square
legend of a sort but unfortunately his
restaurant is not it closed down guys
American kitchen and bar closed out in
January of 2018 unfortunately well you
know it I don't know I never ate there
and then the Oscars do they hate
Michelle Williams answer is yes and no
nominated four times we've never won
Wow if for those of you enjoy a good
read there's a New York Times review of
Guy Fieri's restaurant from several
years back that is just a dull light
they just tear it apart um so I yeah
this was this is a lot of fun yeah Clark
you had me but then just the Paul
Giamatti as the as an actual beer and
Michael Bay like I stuck like my boring
you know Greg I thought you made a good
choice of come on
that Jordan that Jordan cougar team is
is hard to beat
oh but Kevin yeah having a David Bowie
son Duncan
yeah Duncan Jones just such an apropos
choice as director that really locked it
in and then I was picturing your bail
Lennon gets it from me Dan Merle yeah I
mean it's it's it's some of its look at
the job but also it's what you do with
what with the hands that you're dealt or
I'm a big fan of Triple D diners
drive-ins and dives
yeah I enjoy that show however I think
we went a little too far with the double
Giamatti role he's an actual physical
beard is and Michael Bay and it's just
it all seems like well it sounded like
apparently what the New York Times
thought of a lot of Guy Fieri's food
weird bad mix of things that should
never go together so it was down between
Greg and Ken and Greg's movie would
implode the internet several times over
but I think you know it's definitely an
alternate take on Stanley however just
from Duncan Jones to just the concept of
Tilda Swinton as Paul McCartney talking
about love and hearing
it's too I gotta go with Ken Oh had 67%
it was Ken said we had Greg 9% for Gotti
but my favorite comments on Twitter at
fully home and said diners Adam
drive-ins and Beth we are all locked up
oh my god someone photoshopped Stan Lee
and Michael B Jordan it's got everyone
in the studio of flutter here okay so
this is a great moment in sports we are
all tied up at one one one
so now we are going to the tiebreak to
see who moves on to the speed around
it's gonna happen thusly it's just like
basically a speed round question I will
ask the question you will call out your
answers and then in the order we receive
the answers you'll then get 20 seconds
to elaborate and then we'll go back
around in that same order for 10 second
rebuttals then Danielle Dan and myself
will decide who sadly will not move on
to the speed round great fighting so far
here we go
the best part of the Oscars the
acceptance speeches you've wanted ask an
acting Oscar give your acceptance speech
the worst speech is eliminated so that
is the tiebreak question well as far as
the order here we will go in the order
you scored points first so it will be
Clark
Greg and then Kent okay our worst
acceptance speech I give your acceptance
speech the worst speech is eliminated
and do we know what we're winning for
you you're all you're all winning a bad
a best actor or actress award' okay okay
okay oh thank you so much to the Academy
this is this means so much to me to to
be the first person to portray Liza
Minnelli on the big screen she is an
icon she's a multi to multi talent and
you know I think that she represents
America the best of America I want to
thank all of you I want to thank my
agent and my manager
okay time you'll get ten seconds more in
just a moment
Greg oh okay Marcus was tuning up great
Wow the Oscars have had a kind of a
rough year leading up to this point but
to be up here actually means a lot I'd
like to thank my director Martin
Scorsese for allowing me to portray
Robert De Niro in this movie I know he
was very close friends with him so I was
I was a little nervous about taking on
the job I think you did a great job well
I think our editor for making me look
good on camera my co-stars everyone
nominee in his category time Wow Wow I
wasn't remember this is really heavy
offer so I want to thank everyone who
made this possible the lawyers the
agents in in the studio heads to
negotiate in my deal it's not often that
a white man can solve racism through the
words he says on screen but I felt I
really had the opportunity to change
something with this picture and I'm glad
I did it my wife Heather great Sandra
thank you so much for pretending that
you were okay with me being gone for
months you're in Green Book apparently
oh we do I go yet ten seconds more do a
song and dance it's really important it
really matters i I think that Liza is a
genius and thank you thank you guys so
much this means the world to me
as a little theatre kid from the south
so thank you
I want to thank my girlfriend Olivia
this was always my dream to win this
Oscar and when I got that call I just
remember saying to Marty you're talking
to me I want to thank everyone again we
could change the world using glass
straws please support simply strong all
right all right all right Wow ken you
are my hero ten years from now just like
Matthew McConaughey uh can i really
liked ernest clark I loved all of these
these were great but you know I gotta
say the one who doesn't move on for me
sadly a great great fighting but Greg
starting off with the Oscars have had a
rough year I thought just that was a
weird note to start on yeah and then so
for me it's an interesting debate and
for me it's Ken and Clark moving on
Danielle um yeah this is I am delighted
Oh speeches for great so great um yeah I
have to
[Music]
weirdly know I'm changing my mind um all
of these were fantastic is funny and
humorous as Ken's was and it really was
it made me super duper laugh I feel like
his is a speech that at the end everyone
would be like what is he talking about
so unfortunately I have to say that it's
gonna be Greg okay so like that's so one
before Ken not moving on one for Greg
not moving on Dan Merle oh so it comes
to me as convoluted as it could possibly
go
okay I will say that the person who
moves on automatically for me is Ken
because I think it combined my favorite
/ least favorite things about every
acceptance speech at all into one speech
but at a very self-aware way so Ken for
me moves on and Who am I getting who do
I leave out is I don't know Clark and
Greg had very similar speeches but I got
more heartfelt from Clark and Greg's
ended on the weird awkward impression
and I feel like that's the order people
be like so I gotta say that Ken and
Clark move on and Greg doesn't go into
the speed round with one point of peace
that tiebreak did not count for a point
Ken and Clark it's anybody's ballgame we
are tied up 1-1 in the speed round and
here is question number one and again
the speed round works
the same way the tiebreaker just worked
I'll ask the question first person to
answer will have 20 seconds to elaborate
next person 20 and then 10-second
rebuttals here we go
oh just talk about this guy Christian
Bale is nominated for vice what's the
all-time best Christian Bale / psycho we
have American Psycho from Clark we will
go with we will go with we'll go with
Batman which one Batman Begins Batman
Begins great I love this question
Clark 20 seconds begin for you whenever
you speak alright I love American Psycho
I wrote about it and Alicia Malone's
book the female gay is picking up now so
okay this is a performance that trends
that is transcendent if the faculty
wasn't nominated for an Oscar is
shocking the
the pathos the the danger the depth and
the awareness that Christian Bale brings
to this very important portrayal of
toxic masculinity is incredible good can
absolutely Huey Lewis business cards
it's all great it's perfect but today
you've got to fill the cow George
Clooney couldn't do it Val Kilmer
couldn't do it I think Michael Keaton
did it great but Christian Bale set the
tone for modern superheroes going
forward Iron Man Thor Captain America
they all needed to look at what he did
and build upon that he made the
character the mask on is at the end of
the day Batman is going to have Batman's
before and Batman's after but nobody
else can play could have brought Patrick
Bateman to the screen the way that
Christian Bale did I think and it's
great to have fun pop-culture references
and I think it's a horror movie in the
business world but Batman it's Batman
and Bale is the standard-bearer in a
genre that does have a lot of people
everyone I'm Wu how about it let's start
with mr. Danvers very difficult I think
that I think that I'm gonna go with Ken
even though my personal favorite of
these two was the American Psycho I
think Ken had the better argument as far
as first of all rebutting the fact that
Clark's Batman before and after
arguments saying that he still is a
standard-bearer
even given that and also I felt that
just overall I like Kim's argument a
little bit more thank you Dan
Danielle um yeah I got a describe he's
gonna do this I'm like I disagree I
thought that Batman has been Batman too
before and will Batman again I thought
that that was a really solid hit and
while I do he thought he did have great
rebuttal I didn't feel like it quite
matched up to that so I'm gonna go with
Clark I - I'm going with Clark I feel
like she laid out the specificity the
specific specific notes and tones of the
role that much more both good arguments
but Clark takes lead two to one
yeah find out more in the female gaze
alright here is question numero dos
what movie character would make the
worst Oscar host Oh God
worst Oscar host Fozzie Bear okay
worst Oscar host what movie character
Fozzie the bear character um boy in five
Tulley from ghostbusters
Tulley from ghostbusters all right um we
heard Ken first Ken 20 seconds on the
clock for Fozzie Bear Fozzie the bear
starts whenever you speak it is an
impossible task to host the Oscars we're
finding that out this year with a
wide-open job no I wanted it comics
wanted they want to try it doesn't
matter how funny you are you get on
stage in front of a bunch of
self-important people who are very
unsure of their position and want to be
kissed on the ass on front of the
telecast Fozzie the bear would ruin it
every time wocka wocka wocka four four
hours of uncomfortableness
I actually think Fozzie would be a
wonderful host I kind of wanted the
Muppets to host but anyway in a thali
cannot read a room and he just talks he
just talks and he just talks bad jokes
doesn't listen doesn't know how to read
a crowd not socially enjoyable in any
way that is just a recipe for disaster
he's gonna create sorry he's gonna
create some sympathy in the crowd
they're gonna be by the fourth hour are
gonna be like you know let's get on the
side but Fozzie Bears gonna keep taking
shots at the crowd and they're not gonna
like him even that hat is not gonna make
people and deer do anything of triumph
the insult comic dog because Fozzie Bear
is the most endearing lovable
Lucy a stick person that herb creature
that you could possibly fire
whereas Tully is not he's an accountant
accountant shouldn't host the Oscars as
we saw the lava in time all right let's
start with Danielle um man that
la-la-land dig right at the end there
was Wow I got to give it to Clark that
was a really really good dig and she
slid it in just in time so that Ken
would not be able to counter it that's a
good debating right that is one for
Clark Dan yeah Louis Tully doesn't know
how to read a room prattles on can't
take a hint
perfect I agree I thought there's a good
counter argument that Fozzie Bear I
think people love him and they did these
a lovable character and given the - I'll
take the I'll take the trihard bear over
the the completely oblivious accountant
so yes all right Clark
you take the point as 3/1 Park that is
in our parlance game points all right
so game point online did you have any
thoughts as far as movie characters Greg
that popped into your head Topher Grace
from black Klansmen okay three one Clark
this takes it can you need it to keep
her going question number three of the
speed round out of these supporting
actors from vice and I just want to
clarify is that it's the question who is
better in the film or just overall
overall overall out of these supporting
actors from vice who is better overall
Sam Rockwell or Steve Carell Rockwell
Steve Carell okay we heard Rockwell from
Clark first can on deck with Carell the
fact that Sam Rockwell just won an Oscar
is and for what he won at four is beyond
me the guy is a chameleon not only can
he play a leading man not only can he
play a guy that you hate he disappears
when you pull apply makeup and accents
Sam Rockwell I just I'm like in awe of
him and every performance specifically
Seven Psychopaths you
seen that you should I love what Sam
Rockwell did is a kind of down hard kind
of dumb leader in Hitchhiker's Guide to
the galaxy the first time I saw him do
that character as opposed to when he
played in Vice where we got Steve Carell
a sketch comic who rose above that and
it gave heart to a character that was
one-dimensional 40 old virgin then from
there he just explodes to now he's an
a-list actor I love Steve Carell I
really do but even with his Oscar films
like like Foxcatcher
he never quite get elevates to the level
that I think someone like Sam Rockwell
does who is once again a chameleon and
disappears into his roles
Christian Bale disappears enthrall Sam
Rockwell was great but he even even the
one with the the cop one with Frances
McDormand like that was again going back
to even The Hitchhiker's Guide that
galaxy I've seen it before he's great
whoo man what man that was it though I
was a little tough for you guys I feel
like I just heard a little bit more and
just that Foxcatcher dig on Steve Carell
I thought was real solid I got to go
Clark on this one Dan
[Music]
ken was Ken was onto something and I
liked what Ken was on - I liked the path
he was going down but I he didn't he
didn't go all the way down and I felt
like his I felt like his counter was
what was a little wasted I I loved what
Ken was starting but he couldn't he
didn't close the deal for me and I gotta
go Clark as well
Clark wolf movie 5 I mean Ken wait come
back
Clark you really brought it today please
go ahead and tell us where I can find
you and plug some stuff give us an Oscar
prediction if you want ok well I would
say AB you if you enjoyed us talking
about movies especially our older movies
like The Godfather or cabaret or the
apartment or any of the things we got
around was to like it was so fun and
please listen to my podcast it's called
sending the wolf
Sen D ing where we talk about all of the
AFI movies the guest picks a movie and
then we talk about it so it's any list
it can be comedies it can be dramas it
can be score it can be any of that um so
you can find that on all the podcast
servers but Clark wolf com
it's it's there too and thank you guys
so much for having me as far as
predictions go
I predict I know nothing I'm so out of
the loop this year you guys it is like
not even funny so I predict there will
be pretty people there
oh yes that's always for sure most of em
are Saint Howard Clark that was awesome
and yeah I highly recommend you go
follow Clark's podcast and listen
because this was it's anything like this
and caring that much more about classics
and unpacking some of that stuff great
job cat naps are always awesome to have
you make us laugh you make us think you
make us cry especially the cry thanks
for having me back everyone here Billy
business Joe started the whole team here
follow me at catnap suck you know Star
Wars was for Center Clare Jetta console
movie trivia Schmo down cast Willy
talked with lawn Harris Andres Carrera
Rachel Cushing Michelle Boyd a lot of
those names coming into tough Game of
Thrones I got something so big announced
soon I can't wait to hopefully come back
and tell you all about it
and then hey you like comedy March 14th
Seattle Mark Ellis live.com me and Josh
mokuba from the afternoon so Josh and
Ken will be opening up for Mark Ellis on
stage those three guys that's a recipe
for a good time can that suck always
great to have you brother sir uh great
Alba thank you for coming in and
favoring us with thoughts opinions etc
please always great to have you tell us
where we can find you can find me
youtube.com slash the real rejects a lot
of trailer breakdowns movie reviews
weekly sketches every once in a while
yeah it's fun being up here man I mean
the last time I was here was begging
xiety attacked Lee he got to it and then
yesterday I was very sick so I wasn't so
I spent about like fifty bucks at Whole
Foods to make sure I can eat healthy
enough to show up today
wearing gloves so nobody went internal
that's a problem but I just I love being
here this is the weirdest movie fights
I've ever been a part of but it's nice
to have something that was just fun and
not so serious in the last house it was
a super good time and thanks for
bringing back the bathroom key
of course reason I was invited back yes
you take possession of it ah thank you
to our wonderful Dan squared the bands
of the Damned kam Dan Merle and any
thoughts our predictions this weekend I
don't know what it's gonna be I was I
did I did GT e--'s podcast yeah we
talked about the Oscars and he's like
are you looking forward to the Oscars
this year and I said it's a little bit
different than usual for me watching the
Oscars this year is like it's the kind
of excitement when they tell you that
like they're gonna do like a bridge
implosion and you show up to watch you
go into a firework show like usual it's
like they blow up those old domed
stadiums right that kind of excitement
where something could go disastrously
wrong but I still feel obligated to go
and see what happens
total so we'll see I have no predictions
because everything is insane and I have
I have no confidence that they'll even
be able to give out one award how much X
Factor having no host it's like what
have you it's just super weird uh Dan
thanks
again for holding it down and being our
rock over there
Daniel Radford hello I just have to say
Greg chat is obsessed with your gloves
they are obsessed with them they have
been tweeting they have been doing keep
looking over it I think Greg is like why
do I keep staring at me because like
everyone to be talking about these
glasses yes finally here on Thursdays
listen to my wrestling podcast tights
and fights find me on Twitter Danielle
Radford in on Instagram and Danielle
record okay bye Thank You Danielle for
being the voice of the people and I want
to thank the people all everybody thank
you so much for watching movie fights
thank you again to all of our fighters
thank you to Billy biz thank you to jte
thank you to alan nation whoo whoo find
me at Hal rudnick at Twitter and
Instagram and you know there's a great
stuff on SJ news and screen junkies all
the time Monday morning I will plug we
are doing our little Oscars response
video the grouchy's handing out the
grouchy Awards like Oscar the Grouch
yeah that was a name and we stuck with
it check out the grouchy is Monday
morning when we watch the Oscars and
then kind of make fun of them thanks
again for watching bye-bye
[Music]
you